hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast antigen-specific
polyfunctional cd4 positive T cells are
required for vaccine mediated protection
in tularemia presented by dr. Lydia
Roberts I'm Kristina jewel of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
today's webinar is sponsored by miltenyi
biotec the miltenyi biotec mission is to
improve scientific understanding and
medical progress by providing products
and services that advanced biomedical
research and cellular therapy honoring
this mission drives their commitment to
support the translation of basic
research into therapy in the areas of
immunology cancer neuroscience and stem
cell biology for more information please
go to ww emiltt a new biotech com before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or you can use the Q&A button to let us
know you're having a problem this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the cep
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce our speaker dr. Lydia
Roberts dr. Roberts received her
undergraduate degrees in chemistry and
biochemistry from Kansas State
University in two thousand eight
followed by her PhD in microbiology and
immunology in 2013 from the university
of north carolina at chapel hill
currently she is postdoctoral fellow in
the laboratory of katherine dr.
katherine Bozzio at Rocky Mountain
laboratories NIAID NIH please join me in
welcoming dr. Lydia Roberts I will now
turn the presentation over to her dr.
Roberts thank you so much Christy and
thank you to everyone who is attending
this seminars webinar today I first like
to thank miltenyi biotec for inviting me
to present some of my postdoctoral
research today it also like to think rap
lab roots for hosting this webinar it's
a really great way to share to share
science so as Christy said I'm a postdoc
in k bo Diaz lab at Rocky Mountain
laughs this is a satellite campus of
NIAID and at rml we study a lot of
really interesting pathogens and the
pathogen that our laboratory studies is
Frances Allah tularensis Frances Allah
is a highly virulent intracellular
pathogen and the causative agent of
tularemia tillering me I can occur via
multiple routes of infection the most
common is being contracting the bacteria
through a touch in the skin which
results in glandular tularemia another
common and very deadly form of this
disease is pneumonic tularemia which is
caused by inhalation of contaminated
aerosols now in the United States each
year there aren't very many naturally
occurring cases of tularemia the latest
data from the CDC show that there are a
hundred and eighty cases in the United
States in 2014 and you can see that many
of these cases are centered around the
states of Oklahoma Kansas Missouri and
Arkansas so why are we enter
it in such a pat in a pathogen it
doesn't really cause a tremendous public
health burden by naturally occurring
cases in the US well we're particularly
interested in France osela because it
can be used and has been used as a bio
weapon Frances ella was the infectious
agent in bio weapon developed by both
the United States in the former Soviet
Union and it's important to note that in
the Soviet Union these strains were
engineered to be antibiotic resistant
thereby eliminating a very effective
treatment for tularemia which is
antibiotic therapy in the United States
Frances Allah is categorized as a tier 1
select agent because it has a very low
infectious dose as I indicated earlier
pneumonic tularemia is the most deadly
form of this disease as few as 10
inhaled organisms can be fatal up to
sixty percent of the time if a person
does not receive any antibiotic
intervention Francis loi can also be
easily aerosolize and of course this
allows the pathogen to multiple people
many people to be exposed to this
pathogen again by the most virulent
route as i said before Francis Ella has
very high rates of morbidity and
mortality and it's an interesting
bacterial pathogen in that it can infect
nearly everything it can infect small
mammals it can infect our the
prospectors such as ticks it can even
infect soil amoeba so in the case of a
bioterrorism attack this pathogen will
persist in the environment which could
allow for humans to then be a dead end
hosts for the infection but it is
important to know that Francis Allah is
not transmitted person to person when is
a zoonotic pathogens now for such a high
consequence pathogen ideally we would
have a vaccine to protect not only the
public but also our military from such a
bio terrorism threat
and indeed efforts were made in the
1950s to create a live vaccine strain or
LVS strain and this was done by Sara Lee
passage packaging the less virulent
subspecies of francisella tularensis
subspecies whole arctica hilario was
passaged on honor plays with passage
through animals and it was an LVS
stirring that was attenuated was in fact
generated however this vaccine is not
licensed for use in the United States by
the FDA because its mechanisms of
attenuation are undefined and
furthermore even if we did know the ways
by which this strain of francisella was
attenuated it isn't a very good vaccine
and this was known as early as the 1960s
I'm in this classic paper here from
makram and I've modified a little bit to
show the actual doses as she for that
the volunteers were challenged with so I
think this really well illustrates the
ineffective nature of the lv the current
LVS vaccine so in these experiments
individuals were either vaccinated with
the LVS stream you can see here in this
column and then or they were left naive
which would be shown on the right they
were then challenged with increasing
doses of the virulent strain of francis
LOL chew s4 and you can see that as i
said before with just 10 CF use the
control patients all required
antibiotics intervention whereas the
vaccinated individuals only one has very
mild symptoms if you increase the dose
to just a hundred cfu you can see that
three of the people were fine one had
mild symptoms and one had what was
considered moderate symptoms but it just
a thousand cfu which is not a very high
dose particularly given this aerosol
challenge
you can see here that one of these
patients requires antibiotic
intervention and the other two were not
feeling too great and had what was
considered moderate symptoms in addition
to Frances all of the LVS strain not
protecting against very high doses of
Francis all we also know from the
literature that protection wanes with
time and essentially there is no
protective immunity approximately one
year after vaccination with LPS and so
while there is a vaccine that exists
there's a lot of room for improvement
I'm for the LVS vaccine and so this
brings me to for the big questions that
my project is focused on addressing most
importantly we're interested in
understanding what components of the
immune response mediate protection if we
can understand how a vaccine protects
against tularemia we can then use these
identify components in to make sure that
rationally designed subunit vaccines
elicit this protective response in sort
of in concert with this idea of
understanding what components of the
immune response mediate protection we
also are interested in understanding why
the LVS strain that is currently out
there does not protect against tire
challenge doses and why protection
Wayne's over time and once again if we
can understand why these two things
occur we can more rationally design
vaccines to eliminate these problems so
that we have a very highly efficacious
vaccine so in order to answer these
questions we need to have an appropriate
animal model in what was I was very
fortunate when i joined the lab in 2014
the senior postdoc in the laboratory was
establishing this model in the black six
mouse and of course it's important for a
lot of immunologists really use b6 mice
because there are numerous immunological
and genetic tools
are available only on this background
also importantly we were able to compare
two different strains of 80 cc of lbs
ACCC and rml the a pcc strain of LVS is
the strain is deposited in the American
tissue tissue culture collection which
to keep things simple we've called atcc
lbs this strain has been highly passaged
and unfortunately the passes history is
sort of unknown and so but this is a
strain that is commonly used by labs in
the United States we also had at our
disposal a strain of LVS which we've not
very originally termed rml lbs because
it was a strain of LVS that was in a
freezer that was a gift from fran nano
and its history is that it's one of the
original vaccine vials when LVS was
first generated back in the 1950s and so
we were going to compare started out by
comparing these two strains of LVS so
the basic model that we use is all
intranasal infections in c57 black six
female mice we challenge the mice with
increasing doses of either 80 cc or r ml
LVS and then way to 28 days all of the
mice that survived their primary
infection we're then in turn a leech al
enjoys virulent francisella called shoe
s4 and we do our challenge dose is 25
CSU and this is a dose that is one
hundred percent lethal in naive animals
and then from after this challenge we
measure survival so as you can see here
on the Left we have very different
degrees of survival with our two lbs
strains so let's first focus on atcc lbs
which is on the left you can see that
irrespective of the dose that the mice
were vaccinated with again these are
mice that survived this vaccination dose
again irrespective of the dose that they
were vaccinated with nearly all of them
I succumb to shoo s4 challenge with only
about ten percent surviving if they are
vaccinated with a thousand cfu of a pcc
now this is in very strong contrast to
what we find when we look on the right
at rml lbs you can see here that we have
only two groups of mice we have mice
that survived 100 CSU of our ml lbs and
the mice it survived ten cfu and so the
first thing that this tells us is there
are very different LD 50 s of these
strains so the ld50 that we calculated
4rm ll vs is about 170 CSU where for a
TCC the ld50 is almost 10,000 so clearly
there are very different various
characteristics of these two strains of
lbs most importantly however is the
ability of our MLL vs to protect a b6
mouth when challenged with virulent
francisella and so this was the first
report being able to protect a b6 mouth
against virulent Frances Allah infection
with a live vaccine strain of brucella
associational arctica alright so now
that we have our mouse model we wanted
to take advantage of it and first look
at what cells are felt highest may be
required for protection so if you
remember the beginning I told you that
Frances Allah is an intracellular
pathogen and so it's not surprising that
a prime candidate for a cell population
that might be important would be T cells
t-cells have been shown in the
literature to be required for mice to
survive a primary infection with LVS and
then another paper from wayne Conlon's
lab showed that valve see mice that have
been vaccinated
with LVS also required both cd4 and cd8
t-cells to survive a virulent
francisella challenge and so we wanted
to test whether or not that was also
true now that we're working in black six
mice before these experiments mice were
vaccinated with our ml LVS see here and
then 28 days later they were challenged
with virulent Francis Ellis us for now
before and then during the challenge
period with shoe for my fur treated with
either antibody to deplete see for
positive T cells or cd8 positive T cells
and our results were particularly
interesting because like the other
groups we did show that both cd4 and cd8
positive T cells are required for mice
to survive actually in mice to survive
tularemia however we have this very
important distinction in the timing of
the requirement of these cells so in red
is right here you can see that mice it
lacks cd4 positive T cells become very
rapidly to virulent Francis L a
challenge whereas mice that were
depleted of cd8 t-cells while they do
succumb to infection they do so
significantly later on during the
infection and so what this indicated to
us is that mice require on board ready
to go cd4 positive T cells in order to
survive a primary and secondary
infection with virulent Francis Allah
and while cdh are important they
probably play a role later on during
infection and so given this really
important role in temporal role for cd4
positive T cells you really want to
focus on this cell population for our
initial studies a little wrinkle that I
sort of brought to the lab when i joined
was that we really needed to be looking
at Fran
to follow specific T cells so up until
this point we are loud I've been doing
quite a bit of adaptive immunity
research looking at the adaptive immune
response to Frances Ella however we'd
always been doing that for two by
looking at the entire t-cell tool so as
you know the only cells that are
responding to infection are those that
recognize antigens in France a fella and
so while we can gain a lot of important
information by looking at the broad
t-cell response if we can dissect out
the response and specifically isolate
Frances fellow specific t-cells and look
at how those cells are responding to
infection we can learn a lot more about
how those cells are mediating protection
so in order to do this we need to have
identified epitopes and there is one
immunodominant epitope that has been
identified in the b6 mouth i'm into in a
lipoprotein called toll for and again it
has been shown to be immunodominant in
black six month however attempts to make
MHC class 2 customer that recognized
cells specific for this epitope has
proven difficult and so we needed to
have another approach so that we could
look at the antigen specific cells so
what we decided to do instead was to
generate recombinant strains and these
are common in strains would express
another well characterized cd4 epitope
that then would allow us to track those
t-cells using clash to petra mer now the
epitope that we chose to follow is from
lymphocytic choriomeningitis virus or
lcmv the immunodominant epitope is GP 61
to 80 I'll further refer to this as GP
61 we generated these strains by
expressing them off a plasmid we fuse
the GP 61
epitope to the francisella protein I GLC
I DLC is a highly expressed francisella
protein particularly when Frances Allah
is growing into Sara Lee and this would
allow a large amount of the protein to
be expressed inside of cells Frances
Ella typically targets primarily targets
dendritic cells and macrophages and so
it infects a pcs so it should be a large
pool of antigen for those cells to to
present via the class 2 presentation
pathway and again because there are the
tools available to follow this this
epitope we could use existing MHC class
2 customer to follow these T cells and i
want to show here this Western blot so
again we're expressing this epitope off
of a plasmid and so the bacteria have
their endogenous level of I GLC which
you can see in the very thick band here
on that on that row and then what you
should also be able to see are these
smaller shifted bands here for each of
our recombinant strange so you can see
that there is the shift is caused by the
difference in size and we have this
episode epitope expressed and so these
strains do have detectable protein it's
tagged with the GP 61 epitope
importantly we also vaccinated mice with
our RM l and atcc GP 61 expressing
strains and then 28 days later we
challenged those mice with lcmv and the
only way that the mice would clear LC
and be faster then the control
vaccinated mice would be if there was a
pool of GP 61 specific t-cells there to
mediate that protection and indeed we
did see a reduction in barrel burdens in
our mice that were vaccinated with the
GP 61 expressing strains compared to the
overexpression of igf-ii
long indicating that indeed these
strains are behaving as we expected them
to and the epitope is getting expressed
and so now that we have all of these
really great tools we have we can use b6
mice we have these two different strains
of atc flvs atcc and r ml that have
differential protection we have
recombinant strains that can allow us to
detect antigen specific cells we now can
really test our hypothesis which was
whether or not there are quantitative
and qualitative differences in the cd4
positive T cell response and mice that
have been vaccinated with the protective
string which again is rml versus the non
protective strain which is atcc so again
just so everyone's clear about the model
we have b6 mice that are vaccinated
intranasally with 80 cc or r ml
expressing GP 61 and then at various
times postinfection we are going to
euthanize these animals and look for the
presence of antigen-specific t cells by
using flow cytometry and then we also
were interested in the function of these
T cells and so we also use intracellular
cytokine staining to detect the presence
of interfering gamma tnf-alpha and I'll
too so I'm going to start by showing
data looking at the kinetics of the
antigen-specific t-cell response so just
to orient everyone we're looking in
three different organs we're going to
look in the lung the mediastinal lymph
node which is the draining list note of
the lung as well as the spleen I also
want to mention that Francis Allah is a
tularemia is a systemic on disease it
will cause bacteria to not only be
present in the lung after an intranasal
infection but you will also find
bacteria in other organs such as the
liver and in this
and so here I'm showing data various
days post inoculation again with either
rml GP 61 which is shown in the filled
circles or ACCC GP 61 which is started
open circle and on the y-axis we're
going to count the total number of cells
that stained with the GP 61 tetramer
that had an effector phenotype so a
specter cd4 positive T cells rc4
positive cd44 positive and cd62l
negative and so what you can see for
right away is that in the lung there is
a nice antigen-specific t-cell response
an 80cc vaccinated mice on day 10
postinfection see that here however this
responds quickly wanes and by day 28
there's essentially no detectable cells
remaining in the lung from an 80cc
vaccinated mouse now interestingly we
all we never detected from the two
independent experiments that I performed
a large percentage or large pool of
antigen-specific t cells into p-61 back
say in rice what we saw instead were a
really nice pool in the mediastinal
lymph node as well as in the peripheral
site of the spleen and this occurred at
day 14 post vaccination it was most
important about this experiment is the
fact that our mod GP 61 vaccination
resulted in a pool of t cells that were
antigen-specific in both the mediastinal
lymph node and in the spleen 28 days
post vaccination and this is important
because 28 days post vaccination is when
we challenge mice with barrel and
francis LSUS for indicating that rml
vaccination is eliciting more GP 61
specific cd4 t-cells and that these
cells are maintained
into a memory phase and are present at
the time of reach Allan JH okay so now
that we know that there are more antigen
specific cells after our ml vaccination
we're really interested in the function
of those cells but what functions
exactly do we want to look at and what T
cell effector functions would be
important for controlling a Frances
Allah infection so this experiment ended
up being a really crucial experiment
going forward for I think our entire
laboratory because it showed that in
order to control virulent frame facella
infection in our model which is bone
marrow drive macrophages in order to
kill those bacteria you must have both
interfering gamma and tnf-alpha let me
just walk you through these data so on
the y-axis you'll see total CSU and then
on the x-axis you'll see hours
post-infection so the three hour time
point gives you a sense of how many
bacteria were taken up by the
macrophages and are present at the time
at which the cells were treated with
either interfering gamma or tnf-alpha or
both of those cytokines and what was
really interesting about this result is
that shoots for sort of laughed in the
face I've been treated with interfering
gamma alone or tnf-alpha alone it
continues to replicate it doesn't act as
though anything is happening it isn't
until the cells the bone marrow
macrophages that are infected have been
treated with both interfering gamma and
tnf-alpha that you actually begin to see
a reduction in bacterial burdens
suggesting that the ability of a cd4
positive T cell to produce both
interfering gamma and tnf-alpha will be
most efficient and effective
at controlling us for replication in a
mouse and this may is interested than in
identifying the presence of
polyfunctional cd4 positive T cells so T
cells were making both interfering gamma
and tnf-alpha and importantly we're also
interested in whether or not those
t-cells are making I'll to since il-2
with further support the generation of
t-cells and so in these data here we
enumerated the number of polyfunctional
cd4 t-cells in the lung and spleen so
let's first start here welcome to lung
so you can see in terms of what I call
triple producers so these are cells that
make our positive for interfering gamma
tnf-alpha and I'll too and you can see
that in the lung there are significantly
more polyfunctional turbo producers
there polyfunctional in our mailboxes am
I compared to a PCC and these data are
all from day 28 post vaccination because
this is the time point at which mysore
challenge with fearless us for you can
also see in the lung there are more
double producers so these are cells that
are making interfering gamma and
tnf-alpha but not I'll to now in the
spleen when we look at Triple producers
there wasn't a statistically significant
increase in the number of triple
producers in our mall by CMS compared to
a TCC but you can see it's trending that
way and then we also did see a
significant increase in the number of
double producers in this spleen in RM l
vaccinated mice compared to a PCC
vaccinated mice and so so far I've
showing you that we have more antigen
specific cells and that the cells that
are present our have greater effector
function it's in that there are more
polyfunctional cd4 positive T cells
after rml vaccination compared to a
tsetse now I wanted to further evaluate
the functional
bility of the cd4 positive T cells after
vaccination and so to do this we
developed a cold culture system and this
system allows us in sort of a high
throughput manner to evaluate whether or
not a particular cell type is able to
control us for infection so the
experiments that i'm going to show you
we vaccine mice again intranasally with
80 cc or are MLG p-61 we waited 28 days
the mice were then euthanized and we
purified cd4 positive T cells from both
the spleens and the lung and we overlay
or coculture these purified T cells on
to bone marrow drive macrophages that
have been infected for three hours with
virulent us for we then wait 48 hours
and then enumerate the number of CF use
that are present and we can also look at
secretion of cytokines like interferon
gamma but I'm only to show cfu data to
you today okay so let's start on the
left let's look at the lungs so again I
have total CSU on the y-axis and then on
the x-axis we've got the number of cd4
that we're overlaid and this is times 10
to the 4 and so we've been overlaid
30,000 cd4 positive T cells and in my
well so there are 96 wells I've got
60,000 bone marrow dry macrophages so
it's a one to two ratio so now I have
different groups so we've got a no
overlay control so this is bone marrow
drive macrophage the loan no cells are
added to them they're just sort of what
would happen in that 48-hour time point
how many CS used to be present we also
overlay purified cd4 positive T cells
from naive animals of the control and
importantly they look a lot like naive
no overlay naive
no over they look the same which is
important and shows that our system is
working as we expected so what you can
see when you compare again rml mysore in
filled circles atcc are in open circles
you can see that immune mice do control
the infection themselves from the immune
my control infection significantly
better than those from naive mice which
is what we would expect however there
are no differences in the lung when you
overlay purify TV force from atcc versus
arabel however if we look at the spleen
here you can see that when you start to
titrate down the number of T cells that
are added there is a significant
decrease in the number of CF years
recovered from our ml vaccinated mice
compared to when T cells are overlaid
from atcc vexing mice suggesting that
our ml cells isolate from rml vaccine
mice are more functional than a key CC
now this result was somewhat surprising
given the fact that we didn't see
differences in the number of
polyfunctional cells we looked at ICS
and we didn't see differences in the
spleen not as great differences that we
saw in the lung and so one of the
avenues that we're pursuing now is that
maybe there's as possible when you take
those cells out of the lung and then do
them in this cold culture system there's
no architecture to separate the cell so
maybe if they're just sort of purified
and put on they're perfectly fine but
there's something about them in vivo
that might prevent they don't traffic
properly or they're not they need to be
resident in airway and their resident in
the tissue those sorts of questions
we're trying to dissect that out and
I'll address that a little bit at the
end
and so all of our data shows that our
MLG p-61 vaccine mice are just their
teeth are responses better than a TCC
and so the next thing that we wanted to
do was to well I thought actually be
sort of a home run experiment it would
be very simple straightforward I was
going to vaccinate mice wait 28 days
challenge them with TP 61 expressing
shoe for look antigen specific cells by
slow and slam dunk paper no problem
because our ml vaccine mice were just
going to be better than 80 cc all of our
data up into this point had shown that
the data that in the very first
manuscript from Amanda Griffin rml
vaccine might do better than 80 cc all
my functional data for the t cells are
melz better than 80 cc but again this is
why do the experiment because sometimes
things don't turn out quite the way you
think so again we're following these
cells these antigen specific cells in
mice that have been vaccinated with arm
LTP 61 and filled circles and acct p-61
and open circles and we've challenged
them on days 0 with virulence to us for
expressing GP 61 and again my y-axis
here is counting the total number of
antigen-specific cd4 positive T cells
that have an effector phenotype and I
also want to note that day 0 that is day
28 post vaccination and so this is what
was on board the time is my for
challenged and so I think what will jump
out to all of you is that atcc GP 61
back same mice looks fine there you know
in some cases actually they have more
antigen-specific cd4 positive T cells
for example here in the lung and then
the other organs they look exactly the
same as an RM l GD 61 vaccinated mouth
and this really baffled me because I was
actually expecting that I wouldn't even
have any atcc GP 61 vaccinated mice left
at day 14 to even analyzed data from and
so this led us to a few questions well
maybe the Sioux Ford GP 61 is
intrinsically attenuated maybe something
about overexpressing this epitope with
this plasmid somehow made the buzz a
little bit less virulent and now the
atcc mice can survive and we didn't
really think that this was the case
because it seemed to grow fine in bone
marrow drive macrophages there were no
indications at all that the expression
this epitope of having any effect
intrinsically on the bug and so our next
hypothesis was that high avidity cd4
positive T cells that recognize and
respond to GP 61 we're contributing to
protection and what I mean by this is
it's known in the literature that the T
cells that recognize and respond to GP
61 are extremely sensitive to this
antigen and so they can recognize as an
enjoyments at very low concentrations
and so what we hypothesized was that
there's actually a pool of cells even in
naive animals that can respond so well
to this antigen that that's going to
have some effect on what we're reading
out especially in vaccinated mice and so
to test this we got a little bit cute
and used some facts of immunology to our
advantage so b6 in valve see mice have
different MHC class 2 alleles and so as
I've indicated here with this yes and no
b6 mice can recognize the GP 61 epitope
whereas Balki mice do not and so this
allows us to separate whether or not
there is a contribution of
a t-cell response to the strain that may
be the reason why all the atcc GP 61
mites are surviving and so we did this
experiment and naive animal again now
you've no vaccination and what you can
see is that when my firt challenged with
GP 61 the b6 mice when they're
challenged with our MLG p-61 they're
significantly improved survival and even
though this is only one day extension
and mean time to dust francisella it's
extremely very low as you can see my
naive mice died in about four days the
fact that when I walked into the mouse
room on day for all the valve sees
needed to be euthanized whereas all of
these fixes we're still running around
their pans looking perfectly content and
it wasn't until 24 hours later that they
actually showed signs of illness and
needed to be euthanized and so what this
told us is that the GP 61 expressing
strains are better controlled in mice
with T cells that can recognize and
respond to this epitope now the other
thing that we wanted to know was whether
or not GP 61 specific T cells alone were
sufficient to mediate protection and to
do this experiment we vaccinated mice
with either lcmv which of course would
express the GP 61 epitope is a naturally
occurring epitope in this virus as a
control we used fashioned a virus we
used to send a virus as a control in
addition to naive mice because the
shinde virus the antibody response can
cross protect against lcmv and so we
wanted to have another infection that
just lacks the GP 61 epitope to really
nail home whether or not that epitope
was important and when I hope you can
appreciate here when we challenged mice
with what we're supposed to lethal doses
of atc cg b 61 arm ltp 61 you can see it
wasn't quite a higher percent level 4 RM
lgb 6
one there is no difference in the
ability of mice that were vaccinated
with the epitopes without the epitope
are not vaccinated at all to survive
these challenge doses suggesting that GP
61 specific T cells alone aren't
sufficient sufficient to mediate
protection and instead you need GP 61
plus a polyclonal anti Frances auto
response so now we sort of get to our
but i think is the real home run
experiment here which is looking at
whether or not GP 61 improves back team
mediated protection i think that's where
i've alluded to alluded to this and I've
been going through my talk and so in
this experiment I'm now showing you a
few more of our controls that we did so
we vaccinated mice with either a tsetse
expressing I GLC which is dashed and
grey our APC cgp 61 solid dashed line
rml I GLC in solid grey and then our MLG
p-61 in solid black and you can see when
mice that are vaccinated with these
different strains are challenged 28 days
later with shoe for I GLC the atcc vax
name I don't do particularly well
although we do see some survival in the
APC cgp 61 vaccinated group they're
still not surviving to the same degree
that say the rml GP 61 mice are survived
so that recapitulates what what we
expected however when we challenged mice
with us for GP 61 you can see that one
hundred percent of the mice survives
this infection even the mice that were
vaccinated with strains it didn't
express the epitope initially and so why
why is this happening so here's sort of
the model of what we think is
occurring so after a TCC vaccination you
get this small pool of antigen-specific
t cells that frankly might be hard to
detect using our class to customer in
contrast to this vaccination with our
MLG p-61 results in a larger pool of
antigen-specific t cells and then when
mice are challenged with these different
strains of shoe for you can see that
when there's challenge was to 4i dlc
they're not seeing this epitope a second
time and so there there's not this
really nice pool of high avidity t cells
to respond a second time the mice end up
dying of infection however when atcc GP
61 vaccine in mice are childish shoe for
a GP 61 those T cells proliferate they
expand they are able to mediate
protection and so those mice now survive
and then in our RM l GD 61 scenario you
already have a larger pool of
antigen-specific cells to start with and
so even though you don't recall that GP
61 specific response during shoe for I
GLC challenge if we sort of use GP 61 as
a surrogate for the ability of the
vaccine to elicit antigen specific cells
we already know that RM else better at
that and so it's likely that those cells
are the ones that can then mediate
protection and of course then with our
MLG b61 you expand this pull even
further and again all of those mice
survived Sheila's leaves me out of the
conclusion so I hope that I've convinced
you today that vaccine mediated immunity
against tularemia is associated with
mice having a larger pool of
polyfunctional antigen-specific cd4
positive T cells and importantly if we
can include an epitope in this case its
GP 61 they
illicit these high avidity t-cells you
can convert a poorly protected vaccine
which is a ccc into one that's highly
effective in fact all of the mice were
able to survive virilis us for further
and I think what's really important to
note is this entire time we've been
using this exhaustive epitope to do all
of these studies and so GP 61 doesn't
occur in francisella the reason that we
used it was because we needed a tool to
track those cells however I think that
is possible that Frances Ella expresses
an epitope that would have the same sort
of effect and so not only would it be
very useful to identify that epitope and
a mouth so that we can continue to use
our mouse model if we're going to
develop a successful subunit vaccine
that can be used in people we're going
to have to have we're going to have to
identify epitopes that can sort of have
this same property and so that's
something that our laboratory is really
interested in pursuing so of course
there's many remaining questions I think
that we've done a really good job of
answering that first thing I talked
about the beginning is identifying
correlative protection but we still
there's still a lot of work to be done
in understanding long improving
longevity of protection and also the
ability of mice and men to survive
higher doses and so one question is
whether or not GP 61 can improve
longevity and allow my to survive higher
doses I'm also really interested in why
protection Wayne so quickly and so what
is happening to affect our t cells after
vaccination so if you don't have
longevity of protection that suggests
the T cells aren't sticking around so
why is that why don't these cells
develop after vaccination with atcc and
why does that LVS vaccination sort of
seemed to fail to elicit central memory
successful something we're really
interested in pursuing and finally we're
interested in where these protective T
cells to reside are they in the long are
they in the airway are they in the
tissue itself or do they resign the
periphery and then are recalled to the
long upon intranasal challenge so those
are all four of things that were
pursuing in the Bozzio lab so of course
I'd like to thank my mentor dr. akibo do
for allowing me to work in her lab and
provide such a great project for me to
work on and then of course I've shown
you a lot of mouths work a lot of big
experiments in the BSL three this would
not have been possible without our two
fantastic technician Debbie crane and
tara lee who are so valuable to me in
helping me complete a lot of this animal
work and then of course all the other
members of the duboce Fiat lab for their
support and thoughtful critiques of my
science the recombinant strains were
provided by Brad Jones at the University
of Iowa and the lcmv was provided by
Jeff Challenger and Jennifer lab at the
University of Arizona so I'd like to
thank you all so much for your time and
i'll be happy to take any of your
questions thank you dr. Lydia Roberts
for that informative presentation it is
time for Q&A now if you have a question
you'd like to ask dr. Roberts please do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box out and peers on your
screen and click the send button we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for now let's get started dr.
Roberts our first question is now have
you started to look at whether GP 61
improve longevity of protection or
protects against higher doses yeah we
actually we have started those
experiments so in in those experiments
were just using our armel screen because
we felt as though let's take the vaccine
and we already know works better than
atcc and and
those studies further and so I've I've
gone out to 90 days post vaccination
which I know doesn't seem like a very
long time but so far we have been unable
to protect a mouse 90 days post
vaccination and so in that sense our
mouth model closely recapitulates what
we find in people visit protection
wayne's very quickly if we include the
GP 61 epitope during both vaccinations
and during challenge we do see one
hundred percent of those animals survive
importantly if we remove the epitope
from the challenge strain so if we
challenge with shoe for without GP 61
all those mice to come to infection and
so even though we have improved our ml
in the sense that gb 61 can lead to a
longevity of protection we still I think
have a long way to go because it's
completely dependent on the presence of
that epitope we have also looked at
higher doses I've gone up to 2500 cfu
which again it's not that high of a dose
however I'm not able to protect any of
mice any of the mice even with GP 61 rml
GD 61 shoe for they all succumb to fear
like Frances Allah and so I think well
we've made some progress I think there's
still a lot of room for improvement I
mean hopefully identifying epitopes and
using different vaccination strategies
can further improve upon the LVS vaccine
marker Robert how did you purify the
lung T cells yeah so we this was a big
problem in our lab when when I started
because we had been sorting the self
using just a regular aria sorting it
took forever and we were having a lot of
trouble getting the assays to work and I
think a lot of it had to do with the
fact the t-cells just took so long and
we're pretty abused from digesting them
out along and then going through the
sorter all the center fusing like it
just it was a lot and so what we have
done instead which works great as we
digest the lungs into a single cell
suspension with liber8 and then use the
Milton ecd for micro beads and this
allows us to get a very very pure
population of cd4 positive T cells very
quickly I mean within an hour or so from
the digest and lungs we can start to
finish be ready to do set up our coal
culture system which is fantastic and
not only do my experiments work much
better than they did before but they
also take a lot less time would you
expect to see a similar lack of immune
memory with other bacterial strains um
earth if you're referring to I'm trying
to get so in terms of francisella I
don't I don't think we would see it with
a less virulent strain I think that the
lack of immune memory it's harder
protect hard to protect against you for
I think one problem is trying to protect
against intracellular bacterial
pathogens don't think that I try to
remember how many vaccines are on the
market for intracellular bacterial
pathogens and it's very few so I think
in general it's sort of hard to protect
against intracellular bacterial
pathogens probably because we're not
listening and good enough t-cell
response I think it's easier to elicit
protective immunity when the pathogen is
extracellular because antibodies are
very effective at mediating that
protection so I think there might be
something unique about eliciting
protective t-cell responses
is this different than eliciting
protective beasts are responses we have
some great questions coming in but we're
running out of time this will have to be
our last one dr. Roberts can you
elaborate on what you know about the cd8
response oh yeah great good question um
we in addition to generating the GP 61
strains we have also generated a strain
expressing the immunodominant tv8
epitope from lcmv GP 33 and we've also
attempted to make the ot1 expressing
strain system cycle because these are
both really well characterized responses
we haven't done a lot of work so far at
this the cd8 but that is sort of a story
that's really getting interesting I
think interestingly we do see the same
phenomena where if we elicit high
avidity cd8 t-cells we can convert atcc
from a non protective to a protective
vaccine and the other interesting
component of the cd8 t-cell response
that I'll mention is that cd8 t-cells
can control Frances Allah infection
they're not as effective at doing so
compared to cd4 positive T cells and
that might just be a function of the
cells it also could be that the bacteria
is very good at manipulating the cd8
positive T cell response particularly
since is an intracellular pathogen you
think cd8 would be really good at
killing those infected host cells vsio
toxic activity but I'm guessing that the
blog is trying to do everything in its
power to stop that to maintain its
replicative meesh & sewing there's a lot
of interesting things are known to cd8
so we're just starting to to delve into
i would like to once again thanks dr.
Lydia Roberts for her presentation dr.
Roberts do you have any final comments
for our audience
I was like to thank everyone again for
listening to my webinar today and again
thank you to Milton en to lab roots it's
been a really fun morning for me to
share some of my work with you all thank
you again dr. Roberts and thank you to
miltenyi biotec for making today's
educational webinar possible now before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 15 to 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event now
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and hope to see you again
soon goodbye